okay
so um today what i'm going to try and do
is go through
some of the survey questions that we
asked you last time at the end
and trying to illustrate some of the
topics and some of the issues of
behavioral economics using social survey
answers
and trying to give you a better or more
precise overview of what kinds of topics
are we going to
talk about as you know the survey was
anonymous somebody was asking
do we need ethical irb approval for that
we take ethical issues in fact very
seriously in all of the studies that
we're doing
the answer to that is like since the
survey was anonymous and there was sort
of no
personal personally identifiable
information collected
uh uh it's okay to do that uh in
particular in situations where arguably
uh nobody is harmed from uh
answering uh those types of questions um
the surveys you might sort of say that's
not a particularly rigorous sort of
experiment a survey that's exactly right
so the survey that we're asking in some
sense provides some uh
you know suggestive evidence of like
some of the behavioral issues are going
on
a lot of the evidence that i'm going to
show you in class are much more rigorous
in terms of like actual much more
rigorous experimentation
that's kind of hard for me to do in in a
in a short survey
so you think of these evidence that i'm
showing you sort of as suggestive and
then we're going to show you more
rigorous evidence that those kinds of
phenomena are in fact also holding once
you sort of do things
more rigorously okay
so now um when you think about um how do
economists think about
human behavior uh there's sort of
broadly three aspects
in which you can think about that the
first one is
or broadly speaking we have sort of
constrained optimization where people
have a utility function which is kind of
like
uh specifying in some mathematical form
of what makes people happy
right there's stuff in the world
consumption and so on that goes into the
utility function
you can eat apples bananas and so on and
essentially um
the more of those you eat usually um the
happier you are
which economists sort of constitute as
like a a concept called utility
higher utility is good and it sort of
specifies what makes people um
happy now there are sort of like
different aspects to that
you can think of this as like there's
the instantaneous utility function and i
should have said in recitation we're
going to discuss sort of a review of
sort of utility maximization
if you've taken like 1401 1403 1404 and
sort of are very familiar with this kind
of material
uh you might want to skip recitation
this week future recitations will be
much more
general and specific um uh uh to the
class but so what uh what makes people
happy is essentially two things one is
sort of there's an instantaneous utility
function which is kind of like
at this moment in time what makes you
happy or on a specific day often it's
sort of defined on a daily basis or
even yearly basis at a specific sort of
period or moment in time what makes you
happy
that's sort of the instantaneous utility
function and then there's sort of like
time risk and other survival these are
sort of like risk time
and social preferences so time
preferences is kind of like how do you
aggregate over time
like today versus tomorrow two days
three days four days five days from now
um uh how do you sort of aggregate these
up right so you might be happy you might
make a choice today
that makes you today very happy but you
regret it in five days from now
and the question is kind of like how do
i how do you aggregate these sort of
like instantaneous utility uh
uh functions uh to sort of into one big
function those are sort of time
preferences risk preferences is like
when there's risk involved
when things are uncertain so if i offer
you a lottery or if you want to play the
lottery or the like
if you take certain classes if you study
for an exam or not these are often risky
choices in a sense you can do one thing
or another often you don't know what the
outcome might be
in various uh sort of choices that you
make in life
and then you know often some people are
what we call risk averse to say
they avoid risk and and that sort of
like
affects their choices and then finally
so social preferences
that you could sort of say social
preferences in some sense go into the
instantaneous utility function
uh in a sense of like that's just
another sort of argument of that
function or you might say well in some
sense i care about myself and i care
about others and sort of i'm aggregating
my own instantaneous utility and others
instantaneous utility into
a larger function overall but broadly
speaking one part of people's
utility constrained optimization is the
utility function
second is people's beliefs right this is
kind of like how they believe
what people believe about their
environment when you think about like
purchasing things that would be not
usually prices
it would be returns to certain
investment if you take a class versus
another or if you take a major versus
another
what what does that cost lead to in
terms of like your
future earnings your happiness and so on
and so forth
um and then sort of one of that is like
essentially your
priors what do you think about the world
and then how do you update your
information once i
provide you with new information right
so there's like some prior beliefs that
you have
i'll provide you some new information
and you update it to your sort of
posterior beliefs
overall and then sort of
when you sort of think about the utility
maximization problem as sort of a from a
mathematical uh perspective you might
say well
once i know your preferences and i know
your beliefs or your information
i kind of have all the information here
i can solve for the optimum and that's
kind of how you should behave
but in some sense the whole problem is
like solved for you so
we're sort of like um uh done but then
sort of
even conditional on that people seem to
make choices that don't quite fit sort
of the classical economics framework
which is kind of like how do people or
the question kind of is how do people
use utility functions in their beliefs
to make certain decisions
and do we find sort of certain anomalies
or deviations from sort of the perfect
utility maximization in a sense of using
uh uh preferences and beliefs
so there's different things that some
influences on behavior aren't just about
utility and beliefs
in particular the issues like as i
talked a little bit about last time
which are
frames um default and nudges and sort of
heuristics that's to say like
the way i uh present a problem to you
might affect your choices greatly
for given preferences and for given
information that is to say you might
sort of think you like one thing or
another and you have certain information
about the returns to these um
choices but then the way i present an
information or like um
set the default for example for savings
or other sort of choices
people might change might decide
dramatically um differently
um sorry so now um what i'm going to do
is like essentially take sort of each of
these items essentially first
preferences the utility function second
beliefs and then sort of like choices
and decision making
and show you essentially how using
psychological insights
might be uh used to improve people's uh
uh
uh to understanding sort of their
decision making as a whole or understand
certain choices
that people make and how essentially
psychological aspects might affect
people's okay
so the first thing um i'm going to talk
about is a social preferences is kind of
like
how do people think about themselves and
others and much of classical economics
thinks that people are
selfish they essentially care about
themselves and nobody else
is that a good assumption or what do you
think about that
yes yeah i think you can think of it in
many ways that eventually leads
right so one uh thing you're saying is
essentially uh it's kind of actually
tricky to figure out what's selfish and
what it's not is in some sense if i'm
nice to all of you it could be that i'm
really nice it could be
uh that i just really care about
evaluations or whatever so
in some sense it's hard to interpret
from people uh what they do
in terms of understanding their motives
that's actually a very tricky question
in sort of behavioral economics trying
to figure out are people truly
altruistic or are they sort of
doing things for others for ulterior
motives
i want to step back a little bit and
saying like well overall sort of the
assumption of selfishness is actually a
pretty good one in many situations when
you think about people's choices
usually the choices affect people
themselves uh when you think about like
what kind of classes should you choose
uh what kind of profession do you want
to get into
uh whom you want to um uh
marry and so on uh often that's a choice
that affects yourself
these are sort of individual choices
people are selfish of course people are
not selfish um
in all respects but overall it's
actually mostly uh true it's actually
pretty good assumption in in many
situations
now what i'm going to talk now about is
sort of like okay well in some situation
this is not a good assumption so we
should kind of like amend or think about
this
a little more broadly and sort of one
way uh i think about this is sort of to
think about
charity like two percent of gdp is sort
of spent on charity i guess it was 373.3
billion in 2015
which is a lot of money so there's some
evidence that people seem to be caring
about others
in some way now one way to think about
this is to say you have a utility
function that has as an argument others
peop
other people's either utility or
consumption right so there's some people
say
i'm donating money to somebody in kenya
i'm sort of i have a utility function
that says okay this person in kenya if
that person has higher consumption
that makes me happier okay that's sort
of one way to think about this
but uh there's also sort of broader ways
and that's we could maybe call that pure
altruism in the sense of like i'm just
caring about that person if that person
does better um that makes me happier
um but that's probably not the whole
story so what other reasons might people
have to give
or or be nice to others
right so warm glow and can you say more
of what do you mean exactly by that
if other people know that you gave you
can get a warm glow feeling for people
right so you think sort of two things i
think one is kind of like
worm glow just sort of feeling good
about sort of updating about yourself in
some sense
people call it often like self-image or
the like where essentially just you want
to be a good person
somebody asked you would you like to
give money to somebody else
it's not like you actually care about
this other person but you want to sort
of maintain your image of being a good
person and it makes you just feel good
about
yourself right you said also something
different which is kind of like you care
a lot about what others so one is about
self-image what do you think about
yourself i'm a good person i give to
others and if somebody asks me i should
probably give
you said something else which is like
other people i care a lot about what
other people
think about me and so usually we think
of that as called like social image
which is kind of to say
i care a lot about others opinions and
if other people think i'm a nice person
uh giving money sort of helps with with
that
what else what other motives do you have
yes
right so right so that's a little bit
sort of in some sense semantics in the
sense of like if i
give money sort of to pay a lower taxes
in some sense if i sort of looked at
this more carefully it may look like and
i'm going to show you some evidence of
like essentially the fraction of
money that's donated to gp i'm going to
split this up
and there you know some aspects in that
for example if you donate money to
harvard uh for a building
it's not obvious that's sort of like
necessarily um altruism as opposed to
like you feel just really good about
yourself to have the name of
um uh your name on the building uh
if you have a hundred million dollars or
something that's uh at your disposal
but so you're saying essentially some
behaviors that may look altruistic but
in fact they're not
in part because it's sort of just
individual uh optimization so in some
sense
that's more like sort of a
misspecification a misunderstanding of
people's motives which i think surely is
in some of the
what looks like altruism which in fact
um it's not
uh there was some yeah
right so so um if i can rephrase i'm uh
we're going to get to this in fact
in in a few lectures on the social
preferences which is to say if you
compare societies um in certain
societies for example if people do
things like
uh whaling or the like essentially if
you do occupations what you need
corporation
uh uh to be successful in your uh
finding food or the like uh that might
sort of lead to
altruism or altruistic behavior people
help each other
not necessarily because they like each
other but essentially it's like
uh necessary to be able to survive and
then that might
might lead to either sort of like just
cooperative behavior as a whole
or perhaps to in fact people are in fact
nicer to each other so we'll actually
get to that
and that's sort of like essentially
exactly as you say sort of an
evolutionary uh perspective and saying
like
depending on what sort of the social uh
the incentives are for society depending
on what kinds of professions people do
uh people might be nicer or less nice to
each other uh
because it's sort of necessary to
survive or be sort of rich and so on
what else yes
you might have expectations about
whether other people will reciprocate
that option exactly so there's
essentially reciprocity
if i do something really nice to you and
then ask you a favor and
uh in return uh you might not
actually want to do that but you feel so
inclined because i've been digitalized
to you it's sort of like a thing that we
do in society and reciprocity is really
important
quite related to that is fairness right
in some sense if
somebody does something or you know if
if somebody gets paid a lot more than
somebody else you might sort of want to
share that with others
not necessarily because you want to
because but it's perceived as unfair and
people are uncomfortable
um with that yeah any anything
else
yes sorry um
it's not necessarily because you
care about these people directly but you
now want to alleviate your own suffering
yes exactly so that's what economists
would sort of refer to as an
inequity of revision one away the other
essentially sort of seeing
inequality or inequity makes people
uncomfortable
and you know uh that comes in various
forms
one form of that would be as you say in
terms of like in absolute terms like
here look here people
and this is you know i i study a lot of
poverty and development economics
here's people who are extremely poor
it's sort of either like or a moral
obligation or i just feel uncomfortable
seeing people suffering
we should help them to get over a
certain uh up to like a certain standard
of maybe reducing eradicating
absolute or extreme poverty there's a
different version of that which is just
to say
inequality is just uncomfortable and
unfair
overall where for example in the us you
know uh people are a lot richer than say
in
in in india nevertheless you might want
to think uh you would like to live in
like a fair and
just society where people at least have
a a reasonably high
living standards that they live on and
then it's sort of like either like a
moral or other sort of obligation
and people might give because it might
just feel uncomfortable um uh
to them okay i think we said all of the
things that i have here mentioned and so
uh there's various sort of questions on
like various motives
about on altruism why people give and
are nice to others
uh part of what we're going to discuss
when we talk about social preferences is
trying to disentangle those different
motives and there's a bunch of different
experiments that people have run they're
trying to learn about like why do people
give
what determines altruism what kinds of
circumstances make people become
nicer to others or if you wanted sort of
to increase altruism
how would we do that yes does caring
about others
like me like the general population like
how would they look at it is like caring
about your friends or family
right i think those are uh very much
um related there's a bit of a question
overall when you think about your
utility function
usually it's defined for individuals
right it's essentially you yourself how
are you doing
there's sort of other views where you
say okay it's actually the household as
a whole where
essentially everybody in your household
is sort of like um a
unit and then you sort of maximize as a
whole there's a bunch of things about
like within household conflict and
issues that sort of arise and you know
decision making within household might
not be optimal
but you can think of like sort of
altruism as like narrowly defined about
friends and people that you love and
presumably you have like higher altruism
towards those individuals
and then people who essentially are
further away um
there's less of that or perhaps other
motives these things are surely related
but they're sort of distinct i think
when you think about like um your
parents or your family what do you do
for them
often there's different motives than um
when you um
like for example say reciprocity etc
seems like a lot more important in some
ways or perhaps pure altruism
as opposed to like you know inequity
aversion or the like
uh when you think about poor people
across the world
but i think these things are very much
related and the question kind of like is
which of those uh particular elements
are more important in different settings
okay so then the key questions we're
going to ask is like well what one is
like what is the nature of such social
preferences
uh i either motivation and uh to help
and hurt others
we mentioned already most of them and
we're gonna try and understand okay
which of those are important in which
settings
um and then you know uh so one of them
is sort of like what determines uh and
why do people give to others
and a separate question so it's kind of
like broadly speaking you can think of
this as like why are people nice
and what determines to others and why
are they doing that we're pure nice if
you want
and the second version is like called
like social influence is like
how does the presence of others affect
your behavior and your utility as then
to say
uh it might be that you care a lot about
others what other people think or you're
very jealous and so on and so forth
that's not about being nice that's just
about your utility might be deeply
affected what other people think about
you
you're going to talk a little bit about
things like you know facebook and uh
instagram etc uh uh sort of social media
in particular it might affect um
uh how do you feel about yourself and
social influences might uh
uh shape people's um behavior okay
so there you know when you think about
then like why are people nice and this
is what you were saying earlier about
when you think about like where do
donations go i was saying like well two
percent is given
of gdp is given to um uh
is given to charity when you look at
some of those charities you know for
some of those charities it seems pretty
clear that
um people do that because um they want
to be nice to others
for other charities um perhaps um
not so much and sort of some of the
education ones are essentially uh
donations to essentially the the sponsor
like a quarterback at u school
it's not clear that this altruism um uh
other donations if you give for like
health or
or or poverty i think that's pretty um
pretty obvious
okay now what we did in in class is we
so one way to think about social
preferences and measure this a very
basic and coarse way of doing that is
like what's called the dictator game to
measure people's preferences
and it's very simple and one of the
questions we asked you was like
uh here's if you had ten dollars you
could split it into sort of a
hypothetical question uh in class
actually in lecture 12 or something
we're gonna do this
at least at some point with with real
money um but um
uh the question is like if you had just
ten dollars what would you do with that
ten dollars
how much would you keep for yourself and
how much would you give to um somebody
else
uh the other version that we asked you
was um or there was two versions of that
one was the recipient is informed about
the circumstances of the decision
the other one is the other person might
never notice the money is just given uh
anonymously
uh how can we use that to this what what
can be disentangled potentially from
those two
uh choices or options like if people uh
choose differently in one and two what
does that tell us yeah
exactly so true in some ways and in some
way at least you can think of like some
form of like pure altruism in some sense
i would be very happy if you had ten
dollars more on your bank account even
if you never knew there's no
reciprocity there's no sort of like you
knowing or new learning about what i did
or didn't do
it's just like i'd be happier if if you
had more money
and uh therefore i'm giving it um uh to
you um
of course there's things like self-image
and so on are hard to rule out in some
sense maybe
uh it's not like i'm actually happy
about you i'm just happy about
the uh about me being happy about you so
there's sort of tricky issues about that
but it's sort of getting close to like a
form of like pure altruism
if instead you know you learn about that
like either i explicitly it was me who
gave you money or at least there was
somebody else doing it
uh then you know that's much more about
like the person cares about where the
money is coming from and so on that
tells you more about sort of social
motives potentially about the other
person how the other person feels when
they get money how others are treating
them
or perhaps how i feel when the other
person gets it and so on
is there a question no
it could simply be about promoting the
idea of
giving to others
yes
yes right so just to clarify um
so in number two i think uh uh what i'm
saying that's pretty close to sort of
pure altruism
and number one i'm saying there's sort
of other forces of play one of them is
about sort of like
people care about what others do you're
saying in some sense it's a version of
that and saying like well if it promotes
altruism in some sense if i give you
money and you learn about that i gave
you money and the hope is that you'll
give money to others
in some sense you would only do that if
you sort of care about others one way or
the other if you if you learn something
from those kinds of actions
but yeah that's all good i think i'm
just saying like there's so those kinds
of experiments will sort of help us
disentangle potentially
different motives for uh for giving this
is a little course
and we can't sort of rule out sort of
all sorts of things but uh it's sort of
clear that in some sense there's
something different which has to do with
like
people caring about others one way or
the other in some way
you think the results yeah change if you
did it with a margin of money like
500 or a thousand dollars or something
the difference between like getting five
dollars
between like having a nice five dollars
yes understood so um there's only two
questions here one is i'm asking you
hypothetical questions and you might
sort of say all sorts of things but once
i'm actually
putting down money and say here's
actually ten dollars how are you going
to behave
uh so what we're going to do in class
we're going to have some hypothetical
choices then we have some real choices
and you'll look at so how that's
different
in general people choose actually pretty
similar and hypothetical to real choices
then what we will not be able to to
answer in class is how would you
choose if i give you 500 because you
know i i'd be poor at the end of class
um however um there have been some
experiments with like bankers and rich
people and so on but actually they they
gave people like a thousand dollars
and what you see overall is that
people's giving behavior and those kinds
of experiments actually is quite similar
to like smaller
sums i think it may there may be some
differences and i think there's a huge
difference potentially in particular
when you think about poverty and
development
or giving and developing countries
there's a huge difference potentially
whether you give people large
sums of money that could change their
lives and people could sort of you know
invest and so on and so forth as opposed
to like very small amounts
or even repeated small amounts if i give
you like five dollars every
a few days um for quite a while that
might actually not change
things that much because every small
thing feels really small
but instead if i give you a thousand
dollars right away uh you might invest
and
and try to have a better life and so on
so that's that
in that sense i think that's potentially
different when you think about these
kinds of experiments they actually look
quite similar
um uh uh in the behavior at least in
sort of lab games
okay so um now um
how much do people give so the strict
version just to be clear in terms of
like the standard model would say
well people should give exactly zero if
you care only about yourself why would
you give money to others you just keep
everything usually
subjects give around two to three
dollars the average giving
in class was about three dollars in the
first case and two dollars um
in the um in the in the second case so
in some sense
it seems essentially that when uh uh uh
when the person knows about the
circumstance and sort there's something
that's valued more
uh either being like it signals altruism
or just the other person might be feel
happier and and you so do you appreciate
that
um in some way and so here is what this
looks like
you can sort of see the distribution a
lot of people give either zero
or five dollars there's a few of you who
give
everything that's very nice there i do
wonder if it's actually if you give it
with actually 10 real dollars we would
really follow through but surely there
are some
really nice people there's some issues
with those kinds of um
uh games in a sense of like i'm
eliciting your behavior in terms of what
would you do if i gave you ten dollars
with some other student or some other
person
that's fairly rich you know you could
see some people actually saying i'm
giving zero and instead of donating
it to somebody the money to somebody in
kenya it would look
in the lab as if i was really sort of
selfish but in fact i'm actually
altruistic
so there's issue with these kinds of lab
experiments but in general i think sort
of
people's uh behavior in these lab games
is fairly predictive of like real world
things um that we care about
yes these questions
being asked first um and i actually
i think my thought process would have
been different if i had been asked the
questions
yes yes absolutely so i think in
an actual experiment that that i or
others would run this would be
randomized what the order
is and then we can test for that
directly or what you would do is you
randomize across people
so some people get you know one question
and one could people get the others
uh we haven't done that in part just
because otherwise we would have had to
send you different links and it was
already uh
chaotic enough to send you like one link
um which
seems to be like the most we we can
handle um and so uh
but but usually what you would do is you
like essentially you would randomize the
order
and then be able to do that my guess is
that broadly speaking the results would
be similar
qualitatively there might be sort of
like some small differences in terms of
uh the exact numbers and surely the
order of those kinds of questions often
matters
which in some sense goes to like what we
have in number uh the third aspect of
choice where like
if you think about and then the
classical model the order should surely
not matter like essentially i'm giving
you some choices you have a utility
function you have beliefs
and now you should just you'd be done
the order is completely irrelevant
but it turns out that order effects
often in fact are quite important
in experiments and i think in the real
world as well
no that's a great question in fact so we
do um uh so a lot of these experiments
and what i'm gonna uh uh
tell you a little bit about this as well
a lot of the experimental evidence
that's been
uh collected so far has been uh
collected in rich countries
and western countries industrialized
countries rich
and sort of educated people and so the
the acronym for that is weird
essentially
so which is essentially think of a lot
of experiments are done with
uh mostly college students and uh sort
of rich universities
um in the world and you know their
behavior
uh might not be as so in some sense the
hope is that we sort of
uh find universal sort of
characteristics or parameters of
people's behavior
but it's not unreasonable to think that
in other societies people behave quite
differently
and for example one thing that we find
in india in part we do these kinds of um
games with people and there sometimes
people would say like well if i gave too
much or if somebody else did
often we have sort of these games where
it's not just one choice but another
choice
and if somebody for example offers you
too much money uh the other person
reacts and say this is weird i can't
accept this money because otherwise i
would owe them some debt or the like
so there's these kinds of behaviors
where like in some sense it's more
complicated
because of other reciprocity or other
reasons
in china and other countries there's a
sort of a
clear culture of sort of reciprocity
where people are fairly careful for
example on whom to invite and so on and
so forth and whom to accept
uh presence and so on from because you
know in some sense you have to
reciprocate at some point
and if you're not able to do that uh
that's very bad so i think that's
exactly as you say it's a lot more
complicated in many um
settings yeah so just a quick question
about the graph what is the
y-axis it's the density it's like the
the sort of dagger it adds up to one so
essentially it's a fraction think of
this as like the fraction
uh overall it's essentially
greater than one uh it's the
it's a so it's the dens it's a it's a
pdf essentially it sort of adds up to
its aggregates up to one
so another version of that would be just
a fraction of people
but you can't have a fraction
no this is not the fraction this is like
the uh this is the
this is the pdf right yeah exactly it's
the pdf that's essentially aggregates to
one but you could
you could relabel this and essentially
look at the fraction of people the graft
load would exactly look the same
yes maybe you should just do that um
okay
um okay so second let's talk a little
bit about um
uh time preferences so uh one
interesting example and
sometimes i think one of the things we'd
like to encourage you in behavioral
economics or in psychology and economics
is
look around in the world and think about
what's weird or what kind of things in
the world can we explain with behavioral
economics or things that we see in the
world
and you know here's one example of that
which is just a weird thing if you think
about it so this is
uh bet um uh that's called um uh
there's a sort of these betting agencies
and one of these bets is
where dieters can bet on their own uh
weight loss um
success and they often lose so how does
this work there's like william
hill which is a sports betting agency
and they offer all sorts of weird bets
and one of them apparently is also some
somewhat unusual
wagers where people
are allowed to bet on their own weight
loss
and in fact they do that
but they often lose while doing this now
why is this like a weird
bet what's weird about this yes
yes exactly so if you had perfect
self-control and if you had perfect
foresight
in some sense if you understood kind of
like what your preferences are and you
have like plans for the next month or
two
of course there's like unexpected things
that could happen but um
you know if you sort of um
understood your preference as well and
had perfect self-control
you would know that either you can lose
weight and then you would win the bet
or um you would not lose weight but then
you would not even uh
uh start the bed in the first place but
here over 80
of batters in fact lose so now
how do we think about that
how do we explain to this behavior
and so more specifically what does that
mean
right but there's two things going on
potentially so one is self-control in a
sense of like
i have low self-control i like eating
donuts and i like eating donuts a lot
so i'm not going to lose any weight
anytime soon can that explain that
behavior by itself or what else do we
need
yes that's
right exactly so what you need is some
form of naivete or over optimism in a
sense of saying like
i know maybe today i know i like really
like donuts but tomorrow um
i'll just eat lots of salad right and
sort of in some sense this is over
optimism naivete but people are
essentially naive about their
future preferences plus there needs to
be some form of like self-control
problems
and that combination leads to these
kinds of uh
bets so so one part is self-control
problems the second part
is uh sort of like an ivt over
confidence putting these together
could get some people to essentially
engage in these kinds of bets
is there some other motivation why you
would engage in the spat
yes
exactly so it could be that in some
sense i'm just i'm just so
one explanation is like i think this is
a really great deal somebody offers me
this great deal i'm just going to lose
some weight i'm going to make a bunch of
money
um and then afterwards i guess i'll eat
a bunch of uh doughnuts so i don't
really necessarily need to like want to
lose weight
i just think it's a great deal so that's
kind of like over confidence about my
self-control
then i engage in the bet it turns out
actually i don't have self-control and i
lose
the the money i need dots of doughnuts
now um
the second thing that you're saying is
well actually i might actually be aware
of my self-control problems might
actually understand that i have a
self-control problem
now i'm engaging in this bet because you
know as it turns out on average i guess
there's a 20
chance of me actually succeeding and
perhaps the bet
itself might help me in achieving that
goal so that's essentially some form of
a commitment
device where engaging in that bet is
helping me
lose weight i might actually know and
there's a question like are you
fully sophisticated or perhaps partially
or fully naive
sometimes i might know that there's a
good chance that i might actually lose
the money
but it might be worth for me actually
engaging in the bet because the value
the expected value of uh
losing weight might be higher uh than
the loss of money
uh overall right so i think we said all
um there's to say here
so essentially there's either sort of uh
again either people are just
overconfident so naive
second one is people might want to sell
set themselves incentives to to lose
weight
again you need some naivety in a sense
of like or some stochasticity or
something otherwise it couldn't be that
like
otherwise you know you would only engage
in the bet if you know that it's
actually helpful
so it needs to be like some people
either sort of it's stochastic or
they're sort of partially naive in some
sense they think there's a chance that
it'll work
but in fact maybe they overestimate how
high the chance of succeeding
is so overall what this sort of reflects
is there's a a conflict between
short run and long run uh uh plans
there's actually two things going on one
is kind of like what you want in the
short run might be different from what
you wanted the long run
second one is like you might have sort
of like imperfect uh
foresight about that yes
say that were people allowed to deal
with gain weight uh
actually no you could you could try i
actually don't know but um i think
that's
probably easier to do i think um so
maybe they wouldn't accept the
bets or like the or you're sort of like
uh uh quota would be worse
yeah could there also be a change in
utility where you started saying oh if i
i'll get if i lose 10 pounds i'll get
500
but over time you're like oh eating is
actually changing my eating habits is
difficult oh
like working out is difficult so now i
have to pay for five hundred dollars
but not for example because i'm no
longer as interested
right you say in some sense uh uh
there's sort of some learning uh
uncertainty involved yeah i think that
could
could be the case for some people you
would think you know for eighty percent
of people they kind of know
their preferences by now so a lot of
behaviors and have sort of the same
issue like you know
uh i i'm chronically over optimistic
about when i get up in the morning
uh you know every night i'm sort of low
tomorrow at a seven
i get up and i sort of exercise and
write a poem and so on and so forth
and then you know that never happens so
i think while you say there is sort of
like potentially sort of uncertainty
about the world and you might sort of
uh just not know how hard um uh
losing weight is in this example there's
plenty of examples which are going to
show you
is like where people over and over make
the same sort of choices
that seem to be not not optimal but you
think you know people should have all
the information they need and people
should have um
uh learned over time but i think part of
that is like some explanation
potentially is learning that's exactly
um
right okay so then um what we have then
here in
in uh in our serbia i asked you two
questions one was like
um how often uh do you think you should
be exercising
uh the other one is how often do you in
fact exercise
these actually look quite similar they
seem to be one person who thinks they
should and they actually do exercise 50
times a month
which is very impressive i don't know
whether you were truthful um uh
you know who you are um but so if you
sort of plot this um
on sort of um against each other what
you essentially see is quite a bit of
mass below the 45 degree
axis which is to say there's a bunch of
people who say they should be exercising
more
than they actually do and that's sort of
a typical pattern
in the world lots of people think in the
future they should be doing things or
more
virtuous things in the future they would
like to be sort of a better more
virtuous more um healthy person than
they actually are
so if you had to choose for like next
months or next week or the like
you would choose lots of virtues and
good things for yourself but then you
know if you had to choose
for right now uh that might not actually
happen and that sort of leads to this
discrepancy between
uh uh people's desires and their actual
behaviors
um which we're gonna then uh uh uh study
and
uh try and understand and then the broad
question there then is to say well
given that that's the case do people
understand their behavior are they
sophisticated and they're sort of
engaging in certain commitment devices
or certain behaviors that might help
them overcome
those types of issues so at the source
of this conflict essentially what we
call present bias which essentially is
uh manifested in what we ask you about
as well which is
ask you two questions about a choice
between 100 in cash
uh and 52 weeks from now versus
50 x and 54 weeks from now
if you think about 52 versus 54 weeks
from now that's really far in the
futures and two weeks really
early or later really don't make a
difference so most people probably say
something like close to like a hundred
if i instead ask you like right now
would you like to have a hundred dollars
versus in two weeks from now
a lot more people say they'd rather have
the hundred dollars now or like they
essentially like
take like a lower um uh amount right now
than like 100
in the future essentially because like
right now they put a lot of weight into
the present the
immediate present and that's what we
refer to as like present bias
essentially people put disproportional
very high weight on the present compared
to anything
that's in the future and so when you
look at that
it's a little bit noisy and the question
is not quite ideal because in some sense
what i really would like to do is ask
you about
52 weeks from now and 50 uh four weeks
from now and then wait for a year and
then ask you the exact same question
again
now i can't really wait for you uh to do
that um so in some sense
the circumstances in a year from now
might be quite different from what they
are now you might be richer
like more educated wiser and so on uh
but for what it's worth it does seem to
be the case that
uh when you ask people about 100.52
weeks versus 54 weeks from now
the distribution is very close to like a
hundred essentially you don't care very
much about whether you get hundred
dollars in
uh 52 weeks which is 54 weeks from now
if you look at like hundred dollars now
versus uh
a hundred dollars and two weeks from now
i have to pay you like a higher amount
in two weeks from now to get you and
different between now and two weeks from
now which is kind of saying like
you care more about today versus two
weeks from now your discount rate
between
today and two weeks from now is higher
than it is from 52 versus 54 weeks from
now yeah
i was wondering how you could
distinguish this kind of time preference
and kind of expectation of risk like for
example if your
money now is more certain than doing it
from now when i when that might
not see you again but if i look at
institutions before
yes so just uh uh to repeat the question
the question is like uh what about risk
so if i ask you
a hundred dollars now and i give you a
hundred dollars bill and say or you know
uh some money in the future
who knows whether i'm gonna like show up
and actually give you the money and you
know
uh uh there's reason to be uh skeptical
i will be here in two weeks don't worry
um uh but so um there's a bunch of
experiments that
in fact try to deal with that fairly
carefully so they would do things like
they give the
in some experiments with students they
give the professor's um office name they
have the phone number
the the business card uh uh they even
give like checks that are sent
automatically
so they're sort of like people try to
deal with that it's a great uh
question in fact there's lots of
research in that that tries to do that
some people said well this present bias
is actually not real that you find in
these types of experiments
but then people have been very very
careful and trying to
disentangle risk from time preferences
and they find essentially
even if you try to like minimize risk as
much as possible in those experiments
present bias seems to uh persist in
those kinds of uh
choices yeah i'm curious about the
reasoning um
being indifferent between 100 now and
less than
dollars uh you have to ask your
classmates about that
uh uh um you know it could be that in
some sense you say
uh if you for example say uh you know
that you tend to waste money in certain
situations maybe you're really tired
today and you're just gonna say i'm
gonna waste the money on
on hamburgers you might sort of say
maybe in a week from now things are
different
i think there's lots of explanation that
you couldn't come up with again
you have to ask your classmates and what
they were thinking if anybody has
an explanation please let us know
i think one broad bottom line from this
in these kinds of experiments you see a
lot of behavior that looks kind of uh
you know there's lots of potential
anomalies like there's lots of noise
essentially in some of those kinds of
data
um in aggregate you know uh things often
look sort of
the patterns sort of emerge but there's
lots of people make choices that are in
fact hard to rationalize and we're
trying to sort of
look at sort of aggregate patterns well
mostly things are sort of systematic
uh but you know there's some people you
know they're on the very left you know
maybe these are just mistakes for
example or they just
misunderstood the question or you know
there's typos and so on and so forth
okay so like let me sort of just
summarize here so there's um uh people
tend to be fairly uh patient for far-off
decisions so in the future you're
actually quite patient between stuff
that happens between like
again like a year from now two years
from now five years from now people
invest all sorts of things for the far
away future
but when it comes to immediately
relevant decisions people tend to be
quite impatient
you care a lot about right now what
happens the next maybe a day or the next
few hours
you care a lot about that much more than
like um a week or two or like even like
a year from now so there's then two
broad questions that we're gonna look at
one is sort of evidence of those kinds
of uh conflicts between the current and
future selves
in terms of like short-run desires and
long-run goals and you know we kind of
try and find evidence of
of that second we're going to look at
like whether and how people predict
their future utility and behavior
and that's sort of a general pattern in
behavioral economics so in psychology
and economics is to say
actually the fact that people are
present bias itself is not a
huge problem in the sense of like
causing like um
uh sort of welfare losses or uh making
people unhappy
as long as people are sophisticated so
as long as i know i have self-control
problems and i'm fully aware of them i
can sort of
set my decision environment or my
choices such that i can actually sort of
mitigate a lot of these biases
in part because i can buy certain
commitment devices i can sort of like
set alarm clocks and all sorts of things
that might sort of help me
improve my behavior the problem comes
from like naivete
and then to say if i have self-control
problems and i'm naive on top of that
then i might get really screwed because
i think you know oh i'm gonna go do
stuff in the future i'll do it in the
future and so on and then the future
comes
and surprise i'm like really still have
like i'm still present bias and have
like self-control problems so if i sort
of think that i'm have more self-control
than
actually have that might cause a lot of
like bad behaviors or problems
uh uh because i make sort of mistakes
that are then hard to fix
in the future that's sort of a general
pattern about behavioral economics
similar issues like for example you
think about memory if i have imperfect
memory
uh that's of course potentially a
problem but i can sort of fix it in some
sense like i can set myself reminders i
can help sort of other people have them
remind me and so on i can set my
decision environments that
like i can account for sort of imperfect
memory the problem comes if i'm
overconfident if i sort of think i can't
remember everything
i talk to people never take notes and
yeah i'll remember but then like you
know
uh an hour later i've forgotten
everything that really leads to to
problems and again it's sort of like
it's not the sort of the bias itself in
terms of having sort of imperfect
uh uh cognitive function or the like but
rather sort of the overconfidence of the
same that often leads to uh welfare
losses or sort of making people
unhappy or making sort of inferior
choices
okay um so let me talk about
um uh uh beliefs then for a bit
so one a broad set of like beliefs or
sorry was any other questions about
preferences yes
yeah for depressant bias is it
in general symmetrical compared to
loss versus pain so do people prefer to
lose
in the future
[Music]
yeah we'll talk about that in fact sort
of in some sense uh people
tend to so essentially people like to
have gains in the future
and loss sorry gains in the present and
future losses in the future
right in some sense think of it like
this you put more weight on the present
utility than you put on the future
utility
well how do you do that well you you
want to have more gains
and fewer sort of losses or negative
things going on that is not to say that
like loss aversion always happens
uh so lots of version as a concept of
like gains and losses
you're a loss of ears in the present and
you're also loss of ears in the future
but if you sort of could pick would you
rather have like a gain in the present
or a loss
or a gain or loss in the present versus
in the future you would tend to say i'd
rather have the gain now and the loss in
the future
precisely because you overweight
essentially um uh
the present period or your utility
i don't know that but we will talk about
that yeah
okay so let me talk about now um uh
beliefs and sort of like information
updating so one sort of very basic
question that i think we ask you and
um uh that's like a classic question
that like people like conor manninsky
and so on
would often ask uh which is sort of
essentially the question suppose um 100
people have hiv we have a test for hiv
that's 99
accurate this means that if a person has
hiv the test returns a positive result
with 99
probability and the person does not have
hiv a deterrence or negative result with
99
probability if a person's hiv test came
back positive what's the probability
that she has
hiv now that's a very straightforward
question that you can that there's a
clear correct answer
if you know bayes rule you can
essentially just calculate that
i'm sure it's somewhere in statistics
etc people have taught you that
now um 20 22 of this class sort of
answered 99
that's usually sort of the classic uh
what's called like base rate neglect
uh uh for what it's worth you guys are
much better than previous years i don't
know
why that is but uh maybe people get
smarter over time um
but you know still this is sort of mit
if sort of 20 of mit students get this
wrong
surely the fraction in the general
population who gets that wrong is a lot
higher
and sort of the typical sort of
explanation is that they're sort of like
what's called base rate neglect
they're probably sort of the logic is
something like this like a positive
person will
probably uh receive a positive result if
she says it positive she's likely to be
hiv positive and sort of then that's
sort of 99
percent now that's sort of a very sort
of natural and sort of easy
answer in particular if you only had
like five or ten seconds to answer this
question
that sort of a natural response many
people would make usually the fraction
of people who would say 99
would be a lot higher people like maybe
half or more in previous years i think
it was about half
and very few people in fact would give
the correct answer of
50 and sort of the mistake here is
essentially what's called sort of base
rate neglect
is sort of to ignore the fact that in
fact the population the base rate is in
fact um
uh very low it's only one percent and
you should sort of condition on that
when you try to try to solve this
um problem so here's sort of what you
see so 50 is the correct answer
if i remember right but like there's
lots of spread around this and the
the fraction of people who get it right
is maybe like 50 or even even uh
lower than that so now in some sense you
can sort of look at this and look and
the answer is like 50
the the key part here is not like is
this a specific problem and some people
may be misunderstood and so on and so
forth
the point here is that this is actually
a fairly basic problem in terms of like
uh probability
uh a theory this is like a very simple
problem to solve in a sense of like
if you think about like what real
problems you need to solve in the world
the world is way more complicated than
that
however um even among mit students like
something like half or
a half of the students when given like
you know
several minutes at least you think about
this and i don't know how much time you
took
but when given quite a bit of time to
think about it get the answer wrong
that means essentially in many other
decisions you have to act much faster
people don't think about these things
that much
people have not taken statistics people
have not taken math and so on
um and so so the fraction of people who
would sort of get these very basic
problems
is probably much higher uh let alone
sort of much more complicated
problems so broadly speaking
uh these problems are hard often what we
sort of do when we have cognitively
demanding tasks
we tend to have sort of quick and
intuitive shortcuts in some sense
uh think about sort of the problems are
really hard we try to sort of simplify
and make it easier for us
we give sort of intuitive answers to
those types of questions
these intuitive answers are actually
often not bad they're actually pretty
close in many situations
but often they sort of systematically
lead to uh incorrect answers
and sort of essentially then there's a
whole field of essentially cognitive
psychology and so on that tries to think
about essentially
what kind of biases arise and in
particular kahneman and tversky who who
danny kind of are not a sort of
psychologist who got the nobel prize in
economics
with those sort of experiments uh and
you may have read sort of thinking fast
and slow with their experiments they
essentially demonstrated a large number
of those kinds of anomalies and biases
in people's
cognition if you want in terms of like
heuristics that they use for these kinds
of probability and other problems
and these are sort of systematic biases
these are not so of random mistakes that
are sort of added to people's choices
people systematically in in systematic
ways deviate from
sort of optimal uh uh choices or optimal
calculate or correct calculations
and the question is can we sort of like
understand the systematic biases better
and then sort of try to explain
behavior systematically and if we sort
of understood these mistakes better
well then we could sort of potentially
fix the mistakes and sort of improve
people's
decision making okay
um there's another uh question that you
know
worked reasonably well but it's sort of
in some sense mit is a little bit of
special population
which is the question of overconfidence
and it's a little bit hard to elicit
with a simple survey
so what we were asking you about like
what's the probability of you yourself
um would earn like a lot of money
versus what's the probability of what
students in your class
would make this type of money now if you
sort of think about these two questions
at least under some assumptions they
should add up to the same
number so essentially everybody if you
argue it over everybody
if people's expectations are correct
that should add up to the same number at
least under some assumptions
usually they do not the difference is
actually relatively small
mit is like a little bit of a special
population in a sense like if you look
at like surveys across the world
for example if you think about like uh
driving behavior in the world something
like 90 95 percent of drivers think
they're better than the median driver
lots of people think they're better than
the smarter than the the median person
and so on
a lot there's lots of evidence of
overconfidence in the world
so mit is something we had actually an
opposite issue which is like under
confidence
when you look at like uh student surveys
at mit
there's quite a bit of evidence that
essentially and i'll show you this in
fact in class
about like the typical mit students sort
of think they're like worse than the
average mit student
so uh they seem to hear some
overconfidence here but it's in fact not
particularly um
uh uh uh strong so there you can sort of
see there's like some over and under
confidence perhaps there's a little bit
of overconfidence here
but in fact it's it's fairly weak uh but
overall as a pattern in the world there
seems to be quite a bit of
overconfidence in many situations
and then the question is does
overconfidence lead to sort of bad
outcomes
if you're overconfident about certain
situations well then you're going to
fail a lot because you sort of do stuff
that
is too difficult for you if you're
underconfident you might not sort of
engage in certain behaviors and sort of
not try things that would be good for
you
in fact maddie who is currently
traveling
one of your tas had some very
interesting work in india about women
being underconfident
and thus sort of not uh trying to
convince the household members or their
their husbands and so on to
to try and work in the labor market
relates that leads to sort of
lower labor supply earnings and so on
and so forth so if you sort of
underconfident you might not try certain
things that might be good for you
and then the problem is if you never try
it you might actually never learn about
it right if you never even try it
yourself then you might never even
fail or learn that you might be actually
able to do that so these potential traps
of like
underconfidence or if you're
overconfident uh you might just fail
um uh uh uh because you try things
actually not good for you
um and then there's sort of um other
issues about motivated beliefs that's i
discussed this already last time
which is the idea that you might be
overconfident not because you actually
necessarily
believe or deeply believe sort of like
um
what you like to believe but in fact
because it just makes you feel good
about the world about yourself
so i might not actually if you really
ask me like i'm a
better driver than the median driver i
might not actually sort of necessarily
if you make me think about it i might
actually agree that that's not the case
but you know i like to think about i do
things well so in some sense i might
sort of just say yes because it makes me
feel good about um
myself so essentially uh overconfidence
could be driven by motivated beliefs
um uh and that's sort of another topic
that we're gonna uh try and study
okay uh okay
so then um now as i said you know there
are
uh preferences and beliefs that we study
so in some sense you know preferences
about what you want beliefs is about
what you think the world is like
now putting these together as i said
people's choices should be entirely
determined
but that tends to be not the case and so
the one classic survey that's a a survey
question or like a version of a survey
question that
uh richard taylor who won the nobel
prize recently in economics uh had sort
of
asked a bunch of people which is the
following um the question is imagine
that you are
about to purchase an ipad for 500 the
salesman tells you that you can get the
exact same
uh good in a nearby location for 15 off
you would need to walk for 30 minutes in
total would you go
to the other store okay so you look at
this question
well if an economist looks at this the
question is like okay there's some cost
of walking
it's tedious to walk maybe it's raining
maybe not um
and then you have some value of time
either your value of time is like for 30
minutes is below or above
15 if the answer is your value of time
is higher you're not gonna walk if your
answer is the value of time is lower
you're going to walk case closed you
should have done and
you know your preferences you know you
have all the information you need
now i'm asking you like a related
question which is in fact the exact same
questions if you think about it except
for what's different is like
it's about an ipad versus an ipad case
i'm asking you the exact same question
which is the question about
would you walk for half an hour for 15
so again either your uh your value of
time is above or below 15
for 30 minutes if the answer is yes you
should say
if your value of time is higher you
should say no to both questions
if the value of time is lower you should
say yes to both questions
but notice here the questions are
exactly the same
the only thing that's changing is
essentially the value of the item
now why might people still say different
things or what what's
what's potentially affecting behavior
here
yes
yes exactly so we're thinking in uh in
relative terms
which is to say the 15 seems kind of
pretty small when it comes to 5
when it compares to 500. that's to say
500 is a lot of money so if you spend
500
you might as well sort of whatever the
15 more or less it doesn't really matter
but when you spend 30 like 15 is like
half of that like you know it's like a
lot of money so you get like 15
off that would be like a really great
deal
to get but when you think about sort of
now going back and this is i guess when
you go back to like a recitation look at
utility maximization
there's no place for like these relative
considerations when you
maximize utility it would be like the
utility of like
this potentially consumption items and
so on these are all in absolute terms
and either you know money makes you
happy or not or walking makes you
unhappy
there's no relative comparison here
overall
yet what seems to be really important is
um
these relative cons uh uh these relative
concerns and when you look at this um
this question this is i think one of the
questions that's the most robust i found
in any of the surveys i did
this always works essentially people are
much more likely to or say at least
they're much more likely to walk for an
ipad case
than they are for an actual ipad there's
various reasons why you might say well
in this case you know maybe if you have
an ipad you buy an ipad for it
300 whatever i said uh you might have a
lot more money and so you're richer and
so on and so forth so maybe that can
explain the results
there's like 10 different versions of
these questions that all sort of like
have different flavors
and essentially this result is extremely
robust people tend to think in relative
terms and not in absolute terms when
making these kinds of choices
and their choices are extremely
malleable to sort of kind of like
comparisons any um questions about that
yeah so how about joint evaluation so if
you were to ask
people whether you would buy this ipad
you get the 15 and also for the same
ipad case
you get 15 off and if you go there and
buy both you get
a total of 30 off so do you think the
same
behavior to like walk would replicate in
that
i think what people in some ways do in
their heads they do essentially is like
what fraction
do you get off in some ways and you know
if you then bought both i guess that
would be uh
uh i know the prices were it would be
like i guess 530 and then you get like
uh
i think it would probably be somewhere
in between it would be the behavior
would probably be quite similar to the
ipad
thing overall because you would have
like i think what people do in their
mind is to say i'm spending already
dollars
x dollars in case like 500 or 530
now does the 15 look large or small
compared to that
15 looks really large compared to 30 so
let's just walk and
i might as well do it and get a really
good deal i get like 50
off when you have like 500 or 530 the 15
seems really small
that's not really a great deal so why
bother doing it let's just spend it all
anyway
but of course the issue is like 15 or 15
and you know you're going to use that 15
for something else presumably not just
ipads and then you know you should give
essentially the same answer
there's some very interesting evidence
i'm going to show you um uh very
at the very end of the class which is
about poor versus rich people
so there's some evidence uh uh that
central mulanathan and
anusha and others have done that do
exactly these kinds of
relative thinking comparisons with rich
people and with poor people
and what you find there overall is that
rich people do this a lot
poor people actually not so much and why
is that
no it's like for the same amount they do
that they keep their amounts the same
a lot more than rich people right so
they evaluated
more yes that's right and yeah
because rich people have more money they
can more afford to like
spend less time thinking about the
fifteen dollars and therefore
might make like more of
right so exactly so in some sense like
uh so there's two different explanations
one is kind of uh sort of very
in a way like a classical explanation is
to say
there's certain amounts of money that
for the rich it just doesn't matter like
if you like
i have a million dollars like why walk
anyway and whatever i just don't pay
attention
and in some sense i make them certain
mistakes but the mistakes i really sort
of like not very costly just so i don't
really care
i might sort of make mistakes but it's
really sort of like not an issue because
you know i'm rich
anyway there's another view on that is
to say well for the poor
they really at a daily basis they
evaluate something like 15
or 15 for the poor they know what 15 is
worth for them it's
like not a comparison to 500 whatever 15
is like a meal for your family it's
about the difference between your child
being hungry versus um
uh uh getting food or or you know and so
on
so then you know you for them like a
dollar is a dollar and they're less sort
of affected by these kind of framing and
other um
uh uh uh choices but that's sort of one
of the most interesting evidence in sort
of
in in poverty research where people
essentially try to understand
how do people's monetary choices or how
are they affected by
uh sort of these framings and sort of
the
view overall is that the poor might in
fact be
more um uh rational in some sense in the
sense of like
less sort of swayed by framing and other
sort of choices that might sort of like
lead to
a a weird uh or to inconsistent choices
um uh while the rich uh do that a lot
more
uh and the downside of that seems to be
that like thinking a lot about money the
poor then spend a lot of sort of
cognitive energy on
sort of thinking about these monetary
issues and that might lead you to sort
of make worse decisions in other
domains of life you might have just like
less cognitive function or sort of
cognitive energy if you want available
or resources available
for other uh potentially important
choices in in life
and that's kind of what we talk about
sort of in the poverty uh development
section
uh okay then there was um
there was another choice that we did
that usually tends to work and it was
just a very sort of interesting
line of research by dariele and others
which essentially is about anchoring
in some sense looking at this exposed i
think that the questions were not quite
right so the idea of anchoring is to say
if i set you like a very arbitrary
anchor by sort of thinking let it let
you think about certain
numbers in this case it was like the sum
of like people's um
uh phone numbers then essentially when
you have a high sum of phone numbers
you're willing to pay more if you have a
low
sum of phone numbers you're willing to
pay less there's a bunch of experiments
actually done at mit with mba students
mostly i have to say
um but ma students mostly where donna
really who used to be a faculty member
at mit
did a bunch of these kinds of
experiments where essentially you can
anchor people fairly arbitrarily
and sort of if you would make them think
about the last two digits of their
social security number
if that social security number is high
they're willing to pay more for wine
than if the
social security number is low and
there's also real choices that tends to
be quite robust
one problem with the experiment that
we're doing here that didn't seem to
like show up
so in in 2017 uh there was more
anchoring
uh here it doesn't seem like maybe it's
upward sloping maybe not
one problem here is that the anchor if
you look at like the values of the
anchor that we were setting they're
actually pretty low
right it's essentially between something
like 10 and 30 well people's valuation
tends to be often a lot higher so maybe
that's why potentially it didn't work
it could be that you guys are less prone
to anchoring but overall i think so the
bottom bottom line is there's quite a
bit of evidence essentially that
when you anchor people uh that affects
their choices
and again of course it shouldn't affect
your choice at all when they make you
think about your social security number
or large or small
numbers that shouldn't by and by no
means affect like how much you're
willing to pay for a glass of uh for a
bottle of wine or anything else
yet there's sort of like a relatively
robust uh uh line of research
that shows that in fact um that's the
case and for example it seemed like at
least in 2017
um uh uh that was that was in fact uh
going on
um finally i want to talk about
something sort of
briefly which is a quite interesting
sort of literature in social psychology
and it's this paper by darlene batson
which is like sort of like a
classic study in psychology that studies
uh helping behavior
and broadly speaking you think of social
psychology perhaps
as a way of thinking about how do social
circumstances or your sort of like your
environments affect your behavior or
your preferences
and that's sort of like a deviation from
what economists think about usually
economists would say well you have
certain preferences you either want to
be nice or not
or you either want to eat certain things
or not it shouldn't sort of affect uh
depend that much on like your social
environment and social psychology
studies in detail kind of like how your
choices or behaviors in this case i
guess helping behavior
is affected by your environment and so
what they did is like they study helping
behavior
um these are princeton theology students
on the way to a seminar
and they pass an ostensibly injured man
slumped in a doorway coughing and
groaning this is like somebody
in the experiment so social psychology
studies are very sort of rich in sort of
like
creating interesting environments so
they had like this man who essentially
is
looking very injured and they were
looking at
determinants of helping behavior so the
question is do these
theology students stop and help this man
when they're on the way to their seminar
and they had three different um sort of
manipulations
i should say very clearly they're sort
of like a very small sample alert like
the study is very small uh so there's
some questions on
do the does this replicate which is
often for for
for uh several uh social psychology
studies sort of classic studies
sample sizes are relatively small so
there's some questions on how does it
replicate but i think the point broadly
speaking
is sort of a good one which is why i'm
you telling you about this
so what are the three manipulations said
three things one was to had a lecture on
the parable of the good samaritan versus
some other content what is the good
samaritan
parable
yes exactly so it's about essentially
this person who
uh uh uh long story short there's a
person
in need on the side of the road uh
there's sort of like people who are from
the same area the priests and so on
nobody is helping because they're really
busy
and son and then the samaritan comes
who's like an outcast in society and so
on
and he's helping and the point is sort
of like you should help anybody
uh and so on regardless of background
and so on and so forth
so the whole story is essentially saying
like you should be helping
uh uh somebody so like they're these
students now who have been essentially
they've been thinking about this parable
they're thinking about helping behavior
they could sort of supposed to like give
essentially a lecture about the the the
the parable of the good samaritan
and that mind is to think about like you
should be helping others so we kind of
you know determine their mindset and
inside and then in fact they sort of see
the practical sort of version of that
in life the questions does that affect
behavior the second
variation is like variation in time
pressure is just like are people in a
hurry or not
and the third one is sort of like
personality measures in particular of
sort of religiosity so
people are more or less religious um and
you know you might think that that also
affects or
determines how how much people are uh
helping
uh so now like you can sort of look at
like which of those three things matters
so behavior
who thinks like one is most important
uh what about two three
okay i sort of set this up in some sense
um uh maybe not the right way
so it turns out two is in fact and as
you as you
said is the most important thing the
hurry condition essentially again it's a
small sample
but in no hurry about like 60 of people
stopped medium hurry 50 45
and people in a high hurry essentially
nobody stops people essentially
but a reason they're worried about
coming late to their seminar about the
good samaritan and they're not sort of
particularly good samaritans
uh themselves it turns out that
personality characteristics don't seem
to really predict behaviors
and so what we learned from that is that
um a personality
sorry that situations can matter a great
deal now in some sense that's very much
consistent what i was saying
to you earlier about like social
influences affect behavior in some sense
in the sense of like uh you care about
others
um in a way depends a lot on like uh
your circumstances in the sense of like
are you observed or not or like
uh uh it's sort of malleable situations
but i think since
here's like a choice that's exactly the
same choice like you might either be
nice or not
but in some sense the value of time
seems to be quite important here for
people
so like people's choices in some sense
uh might actually be
it's not like you're a nice person
versus not but in some situations you
might behave very nicely and friendly
and in others
not so much and that's sort of a much
more sort of fundamental problem perhaps
for
uh for economics so for writing down
utility functions
because essentially the issue is that
it's not even clear what your social
preference parameter is it's not even
clear are you a nice person or not some
a nice person because it depends so much
on like your environment and people are
shaped by their environments
overall so one thing we're going to
think about towards the end of the class
is to say
well people's it's not just that their
preferences or their beliefs sort of
systematically deviate in ways that we
can quantify
from the classical model but in fact
it's the case that
they're actually very volatile and maybe
even hard to elicit in some ways because
it's sort of changing uh so much
and in fact people might not even know
necessarily
their preferences or their preferences
are just sort of malleable in the sense
of like they depend a lot on uh
circumstantial
um situations uh okay
so then let me sort of summarize um uh
quickly of what we um discussed
so i think one way and that's what i was
saying earlier one way to think about
this class is
uh one goal of this class is sort of
like really to get you
to think more and observe the world more
in a way through the lens of economics
but also through the lens of sort of
psychology and economics
that's to say you can think about like a
lot of situations or people behave and
try to understand why they behave in the
ways that they do and you often sort of
see certain puzzles or certain behaviors
that
don't look quite right it seems like
people are sort of making mistakes
in some ways they seem to be sort of
erratic in various ways but often we can
actually put a lot of structure in their
behavior we can actually understand
systematically through certain puzzles
or certain sites through certain uh
theories or certain topics that we
discussed in class
what people do and why they do that
there's also similar issues about like
firms when you think about when you get
like credit card offers when you think
about like
uh a sales item and so on when you think
about like
pricing decisions at firm make a lot of
these pricing or decisions that firm
make are actually
very thinking very carefully about the
psychology of consumers
so essentially what firms are doing
they're trying to think about sort of
potential what we call a behavioral
biases or issues that
consumers have and when you sort of
think about what you see in the world
often that makes actually a lot of sense
through the lens of sort of psychology
economics or behavioral
economics so you can sort of think about
yourself or others when you see certain
products
think about sort of how do we how does
this relate to the content of the course
that we have and i think that's that's a
general sort of lesson so what we try to
do in the course in part is
think about individual choices and sort
of some theories um in economics and
psychology
but in particular and think about like
how do these series and relate to like
real world outcomes
how can we perhaps apply them to
situations um uh and the world
and potentially um improve uh choices
so here's sort of like broadly where we
are as i said you know
we're going to talk about preferences um
for the next sort of few
a few weeks in particular time
preferences and self-control
as i said you know a lot of that is to
do with procrastination
including for problem sets as i said the
problem set will come probably something
around
uh monday um
[Music]
here's the reading for next week this is
on the course website please read
frederick adele
2002 sections one as well as 4.1 to
5.1 thank you very much